they make it their business to mind your
business state Rep Luis Arroyo authored
a bill that would make it illegal to
sell just about any kind of energy drink
to anyone under 18 and then there's this
they will come to your home and remove
your dog dog lovers in Oklahoma are
sounding off against a bill cooked up by
state senator Patrick Anderson that
would let cities ban big breeds and
states that have passed similar
legislation those who owned their pets
prior to the change we're not
grandfathered in but hey how about this
thanks to a social media backlash
Anderson ditched the bill but enough
with the good news here's your nanny
that kind of thing doesn't belong here
in small town we as a community o our
young girls more I would have very much
appreciate that you reflect the values
of this community and say no to bikini
baristas thank you after Shelton
Washington slapped a temporary
moratorium on drive-through coffee shops
staffed with scantily clad ladies
townspeople demanded a permanent ban on
bikini baristas but this Commissioner
suggested a novel alternative to calling
upon the force of law don't like bikini
baristas buy your coffee somewhere else
if enough people are on your side
they'll go out of business and maybe
that used to be the American Way but the
mayor knows how to connect with today's
voters if we have following any of the
month on Twitter submit your nanny
nominees and click here to watch another
episode